- [Voiceover] In this video,
we're going to be talking about
how you can write electron configurations
using noble gas notation.
And to be more specific,
in this video we're also
going to be focusing
on examples using main group elements.
So, we're doing that because
the transition metals,
right here, and the lanthanides,
are a little bit more complicated,
so we won't be doing that
in this particular video.
So the rule for writing
the noble gas notation for something
is pretty simple.
It is,
you take the noble gas
immediately preceding your atom or ion,
so what do I mean by
immediately preceding?
That means we want the
noble gas that comes
right before it, so you go up a row,
and you go over to here,
where the noble gases live.
And you put that in brackets
and then you write your other
electrons, and you write
your other electrons
using the same notation
that you normally write
electron configurations in.
If you don't remember what that is,
we'll go through a couple
examples right now.
So hopefully it will become more clear.
So before we get started,
I'm just going to remind you
why we call the noble gases
noble,
and that is because they have a full octet
of electrons.
And so, since they have a
full octet, they're not very
reactive, they have all of the electrons
they want,
and as a result,
you will see in chemistry
that a lot of chemistry,
chemical reactions will be driven by other
non-noble gases trying
to get a full octet.
So the first example
we're going to talk about
and write the configuration
for is silicon.
Silicon is right below
carbon in the Periodic Table,
and we can write its full
electron configuration,
just for comparison,
so if we start up here,
with hydrogen, silicon has
the electron configuration
1s2
2s2
2p6,
so as a reminder, these
are our S electrons
because they're in S orbitals.
These are our P electrons
because they're in P orbitals,
and then once we're
through our 2p6 electrons,
we go to 3s2
and we have two more electrons,
so it's 3p2.
So that's the electron
configuration for silicon.
Now, we can write it out
using noble gas notation.
And compare, so,
the noble gas immediately
preceding silicon,
if we go up a row and then move over,
we see that it's neon.
So we write neon in brackets.
And then,
the other electrons
are the ones that come after neon.
So we go down,
and the electrons that
aren't included in neon
would be our
3s2 electrons, right here,
and the 3p2 electrons.
So if we compare these two ways of writing
our electron configuration,
you can see that
these electrons right here,
so everything up to 3s2 3p2,
that gives us the electron
configuration for neon.
And so we don't have to write that,
we just write neon,
and assume that whoever's reading it
knows what the electron
configuration for neon is.
The other thing you might notice is that
these other electrons here,
that we wrote outside of the brackets,
these are our valence electrons.
So, writing
your electron configuration this way,
using noble gas notation,
makes it really obvious where
your valence electrons are
and what kind they are,
so that's helpful.
We are going to go
through one more example
and that will be calcium.
So calcium is over here,
and so, we're not going
to write the full electron
configuration this time.
We're just going to write
the noble gas notation.
So calcium, the noble gas
immediately preceding it,
we go up a row and then
over and we see that
the noble gas is argon,
so we write argon in our brackets,
and then, what electrons are not in argon?
So we move down and we
see that we have our
4s electrons, and we have two of them.
So this is the noble gas
configuration for calcium.
So does calcium have a full octet?
And we know that these
are the valence electrons
and we also know that if
it did have a full octet,
it would actually already have
a noble gas configuration,
so it would either have krypton or argon
and in this case, it
turns out that calcium
prefers to lose two electrons,
as opposed to gaining a bunch.
It would be gaining 10 plus six.
So, lose two electrons,
and when calcium loses two
electrons, it becomes the
calcium 2-plus cation.
And then we can write
the electron configuration really short,
or it'll be really short
because we know it's going
to lose these two valence
electrons and then,
it will have the electron
configuration which is just
the same as argon.
And we can tell, really
easily, looking at this,
that calcium 2-plus has a full octet.
So, one of the
many pros of writing things
in noble gas notation,
besides the fact that it, you know,
makes your hand less tired,
is that it makes it
really easy to see where
your valence electrons are,
and whether or not your ion
or atom has a full octet.